es gab wieder Streit in der
Bundesregierung aber alle gehen schon
davon aus dass beides kommen wird im
August das wachstumschancengesetz und
die Kindergrundsicherung sie haben jetzt
eine Agenda 2030 so haben sie das
genannt gefordert und Deutschland
wettbewerbsfähiger zu machen was würden
Sie denn anders machen als die
Bundesregierung ich würde erstmal
handeln wir merken das zum Beispiel beim
Thema Flüchtlinge da gab es ein Gipfel
im Mai die Bürgermeister schreiben mich
an die Landräte schreiben mich an und
sagen warum gab es überhaupt den Gipfel
wo ist die Unterstützung dann das Thema
Wirtschaft natürlich sehr stark der
Mittelstand ist völlig verunsichert hat
keine Planungssicherheit sie haben es
angesprochen da wurde mal eben ein
Gesetz von der Tagesordnung genommen wo
man mit
gerechnet hat das Thema Liquidität das
ist bessere Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
gibt dass es mehr Geld gibt
Unterstützung in der jetzigen Situation
also ich würde wirklich den Finger in
die Wunde legen und einen Sofortprogramm
vorlegen was können wir den nächsten
vier Wochen machen
die Frage ist ob sie damit bei den
Menschen ankommen mit ihrer aktuellen
Politik und ihren Plänen im aktuellen
ZDF Politbarometer hat etwas mehr als
die Hälfte der Befragten 52 Prozent
gesagt die Union würde es auch nicht
besser machen und diese Zahlen die wir
jetzt gleich zeigen werden dürften Ihnen
auch Sorgen bereiten wir haben nicht
gefragt würde sich Friedrich Merz als
Bundeskanzler eignen lediglich 22% aller
Befragten sind der Meinung dass sich der
CDU-Vorsitzende als Bundeskanzler eignen
wird in 69% sehen das nicht so und hier
auf der rechten Seite auch bei den
cdu/csu Anhängern halt nur 39% märz für
geeignet als Bundeskanzler und 50%
finden ihn für das Amt des
Bundeskanzlers also von den eigenen
Leuten ungeeignet wie erklären Sie sich
diese Zahlen ich glaube es gibt einen
Punkt der ist berechtigt dass viele
Menschen sagen was sind denn eure
Konzepte was macht ihr denn besser wir
haben gerade über das Thema Wirtschaft
gesprochen wir werden jetzt in zwei
Wochen ein Konzept vorlegen was wir
besser machen würden dass wir nicht nur
kritisieren sondern viel besser machen
und darüber hinaus zeigen die aktuellen
Werte auch für die CDU auch eine
Unzufriedenheit mit der ampelregierung
ich meine das muss man sich mal
vorstellen erstmal was wir gerade
gesehen haben eine Unzufriedenheit auch
mit dem CDU-Vorsitzenden nee insgesamt
dass man sagt die Opposition muss klarer
sagen was sie denn will das gilt für
Friedrich Merz das gilt für mich auch
als Generalsekretär und genau daran
arbeiten wir nur wenn die Ampel wirklich
den letzten verunsichert hat in
Deutschland mit dem heizungsgesetz dann
braucht man sich nicht wundern das
Protest entsteht und das passiert gerade
und daran kann niemanden Interesse haben
bleiben wir noch kurz bei der Union alle
fragen sich natürlich wer wird
Kanzlerkandidat diese Frage können Sie
wahrscheinlich jetzt schon sie sind
gerade fünf Wochen Generalsekretär nicht
mehr hören ich stelle sie aber trotzdem
oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders
vielleicht können sie auch nicht mehr
bis Herbst nächsten Jahres warten zu
entscheiden wer es wird aber die Frage
ist vor allem wie wollen Sie entscheiden
sollen es die Gremien entscheiden wie
bisher eigentlich in den letzten Jahren
oder doch die Mitgliederinnen und
Mitglieder der Union
bundeskanzlerkandidat die Parteien
führen sollen ja ich teile ihren Punkt
nicht sie sagen gerade jeder
interessiert sich dafür wer
Kanzlerkandidat wird ich war das ganze
Wochenende wieder im Wahlkreis unterwegs
auf festen habe viele Leute getroffen
nicht einer hat mich gefragt sondern die
Menschen fragen sich was macht ihr denn
bei sechs bis sieben Prozent Inflation
die Mittelständler haben keine
Fachkräfte mehr Restaurants machen zu
die fangen an mittags zuzumachen nur
noch abends auf ganze hauen ganze ab
ganze Restaurants schließen ganz die
Industrie verlegt ihren Sitz ins Ausland
um Kosten zu sparen das sind die Themen
es ist wirklich so ich kriege diese
Frage nur in Berlin gestellt und wir
haben ein ganz klaren Fahrplan im
nächsten Spätsommer Herbst werden wir
diese Frage beantworten da wird's ein
Gespräch natürlich der Parteivorsitzende
geben natürlich werden die
Parteivorsitzenden sich zusammensetzen
und dann darüber reden und dann werden
auch andere mitgenommen sie wollen über
Themen sprechen das ist ja auch
verständlich ihr Fraktions hat sich am
Wochenende gemeldet und hat das Thema
Migration auf die Agenda gesetzt und
fordert jetzt eine Pause von dieser völ
untersteuerten ungesteuerten
asylmigration dabei haben sich ja die
EU-Staaten gerade auf eine Verschärfung
des Asylrechts geeinigt das haben sie
gemacht das Problem ist nur bei der EU
das ist immer sehr lange dauert diese
Einigung wird wahrscheinlich nicht
Monate dauern in der Umsetzung sondern
vielleicht sogar ein zwei drei Jahre und
so lange haben wir keine Zeit reden sie
mal mit Bürgermeister und Landräten wir
wollen ja als Deutschland Humanität
zeigen aber wenn wir überfordert sind
schaffen wir das nicht und damit lieber
leider das war was der Bundespräsident
aD sagt Joachim Gauck unser Herz ist
weiter aber unsere Möglichkeiten sind
endlich und deshalb muss jetzt gehandelt
werden ich habe es eben gesagt der
flüchtlingsgipfel liegt Monate zurück es
passiert einfach nicht der Kanzler duckt
sich auch weg er geht auf einer
abstrakte Ebene spricht über
Themen beantwortet Fragen nicht also ich
habe das Gefühl dass es keine
fortschrittskoalition mehr sondern eine
Abstieg Koalition man muss das wirklich
leider so sagen ganz kurz auf sie
arbeiten an einem CDU Grundsatzprogramm
und sie sprechen geben sie uns drei
Punkte was die Union wirklich
unterscheidet und was sie jetzt mit
welchen Akzenten sie jetzt in diese
nächsten zwei Jahre gehen wollen
wo ich gestern auch mit vielen darüber
gesprochen habe ein gesellschaftsjahr
nur die Union fordert ein
gesellschaftsjahr dass wir sagen es tut
jungen Menschen gut nach der Schule für
eine bestimmte Zeit nicht nur bei der
Bundeswehr im sozialen Bereich
europäisches Ausland vielleicht nimmt
man Vereine und Stiftung dazu ja sich zu
treffen dass man sieht das anders denken
da auch eine Meinung haben dass die
Gesellschaft zusammenhält nur mal einen
Punkt darüber hinaus das Thema leisten
das Leistung honoriert wird das Fördern
und Fordern wieder ignoriert auch das
fordern beim Bürgergeld und wir brauchen
einen funktionierenden Staat und ein
Rechtsstaat der funktioniert das Recht
in Deutschland durchgesetzt wird sagt
Carsten Lindemann der
CDU-Generalsekretär vielen Dank für das
Interview ich danke Ihnen